Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
And tonight,
Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made
billionaire investor Chris Sacca
joins the tank.
This is the highest valuation
we've ever had on "Shark Tank."
We've never had any company
for $40 million.
It scares the hell
out of me.
You've got the most valuable
prime time airtime in the world
right now,
and you're blowing it.
Oh, I ‐‐ No disrespect.
Herjavec: Regardless of
what Chris Sacca thinks,
the wannabe Millennial ‐‐
Man, sometimes you sound
really old.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
Herjavec: You're not giving us
that answer.
We've asked you that
like 20 times.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
The best deals are ones
where you squirm a little bit.
I want to see you squirm.
Narrator:
First into the tank is a company
hoping to revolutionize
personal transportation.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Ryan Evans.
I'm Dave Evans.
And I'm Chris Haley.
We're from Santa Cruz,
California,
and our company is
Inboard Technology.
We are seeking $750,000
in exchange
for a 4% equity stake
in our company.
[ Chuckles ]
Sharks, let's face it.
Getting around urban areas ‐‐
It sucks!
Jam‐packed in
a crowded public transportation
or stuck in gridlock
on your drive home,
and just when you think you've
beaten the system
by riding a bike to work,
you show up looking like
a hot, sweaty mess.
Our solution is the M1.
The M1 is
an electric skateboard
that goes
up to 20 miles an hour
and has a range
of 7 to 10 miles.
We've integrated headlights
and taillights
so you're safe
when you ride at night.
Our in‐wheel
motor technology...
[ Motor whirs ]
... has no moving belts,
no gears,
and requires no maintenance.
All this while looking and
feeling like a real skateboard.
At 14 pounds,
you can easily carry the M1
into a crowded elevator,
and I think
we can all agree
that parking is not
gonna be a problem.
Sharks, we're on the verge
of a transportation revolution.
Riding the M1 can turn
your commute into a fun, easy,
and exciting experience,
and all for less than the cost
of car insurance.
Now, which one
of you Sharks
wants to get onboard
with Inboard?
And more importantly, who wants
to come up and try the M1?
O'Leary:
I want to try that thing.
I'll give it a shot.
Kevin, here we go.
All right.
So it's really easy
to use.
All right.
The big thing is that
you've got
four contact points
with the ground.
Yeah.
So, it's really stable.
Will it support
Kevin's weight?
[ Laughter ]
We've actually tested it up to
1,200 pounds ‐‐ very strong.
This is the safety.
So, you hold this to engage.
It's just forward to go forward
and back to go back.
So, I can't move it
unless I'm pushing this, right?
Exactly.
There we go.
Herjavec: You might want to hold
Kevin's hand at the beginning.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Ryan: There you go.
And pull back to brake.
Very cool.
Yeah, and he's gone.
See you later,
kiddies.
Ryan:
Oh, there he goes.
Sacca: He shreds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah, baby.
Okay, I like it.
I like it.
Yeah.
It's very cool.
Looking very good, Kevin.
There you go.
That's 'cause I'm very hip.
That's it.
Yeah.
I'm a skater dude.
I'm pretty sure there's other
electric skateboards out there.
Ryan:
Yeah, that's correct.
Why is yours unique?
The fact that we created
the first ever in‐wheel motor.
It's actually
one of the smallest
hub motors ever created.
The way we integrated
the battery into the deck.
But, really,
the biggest difference
between us
and our competitors
is the way
that we designed our company.
From inception,
we've focused on scalability,
high‐volume manufacturing,
and high‐volume distribution.
Cuban:
How much have you raised?
To date,
it's been $2.7 million.
Greiner: Wow.
What was the value of the
company after your last round?
We had a $10 million valuation
after our last round.
So, did you say
it can go uphill?
Yes.
And going downhill,
what happens?
It actually ‐‐ It brakes,
and it charges the battery
while you brake.
The greatest thing about
the in‐wheel motor technology ‐‐
If you look at any of
our competitors on the market,
they all use an external motor
that sits outside
and then ultimately,
a gear and a belt system
that drives the motor.
But, Ryan,
it's a skateboard.
Yes.
It's a toy.
Haley:
We would disagree with that.
A lot of people see that
as their vehicle.
Really?
Cuban:
But that's a niche market.
Nobody is gonna commute to work
with a skateboard
that isn't commuting to work
with a skateboard today.
Man, sometimes,
you sound really old.
This is happening today
at scale.
Really?
Yeah, maybe not in Toronto
because you have to
dig out of snow half the year,
but here in California,
it's happening at scale.
I actually do see them
as a vehicle or as a tool.
Yeah, but when Chris
talks about scale, he's wrong.
Just because you see individuals
driving around on skateboards
doesn't mean it's scale.
One of my companies
is working on re‐inventing
the self‐balancing
"Hoverboards," right?
Mm‐hmm.
There's challenges
there, right?
Absolutely.
There's laws in terms of riding
on the sidewalks.
There's inclines.
There's bumps in the road.
You're absolutely right.
And so, we've got some IP
currently pending on some new
form factors and designs
that'll blow you away.
I just want to know ‐‐
What does it cost?
The retail price
is $1,399.
And what does it cost
to make?
We have have
a direct margin of 65%.
How many people
can afford $1,400?
The self‐balancing boards,
when they first came out,
were 1,500 bucks, and they ‐‐
they sold hundreds of thousands.
Ryan: Yeah.
So, people want
a better way.
Wait, didn't you just tell me
that I'm wrong about scale,
that this isn't
gonna scale?
It's a whole
different beast.
The skateboard market
is completely different
than the Hoverboard
'cause one is a lot easier
to balance on.
It's a lot easier to go forward
and backwards.
You don't hang out
on YouTube enough
to see all the Hoverboard
fail videos, man.
No, you're wrong there.
Because not only have I seen
all the YouTube videos,
I've read the patents,
so I know what's going on.
They're
two different markets.
One is to get around
your neighborhood, have fun.
They weren't really definitive
modes of transportation
to go to work.
I see that market.
Right.
For sure.
So, that's why
they sold more.
This, in terms of being a way
to get to work ‐‐
I don't think
it's big enough right now
for you to say you're gonna
change how people go to work.
Haley:
'When I lived in Manhattan,
I basically planned my life
around traffic.
The M1 ‐‐ It's very easy
to pick up and take in a subway,
unlike a bike.
If it starts to rain,
I can call an Uber,
and I can put it
right in the trunk.
But can I go back to one thing?
Have you sold any? Right?
[ Chuckling ]
Great question.
So, we set up
nine global distributors
that are gonna carry
our product.
We have $5.6 million
in pre‐orders
with those distributors,
which we'll be able to fulfill
by the end
of this year.
And people that live
in apartments ‐‐
O'Leary: I think we've seen
the merits of the product.
We understand the risks.
I'm interested.
So, I'm thinking about
structuring an offer here.
You need capital,
so what about a deal like this?
I'll drop the equity ask
down to 2.5%,
and I'll loan you
the $750,000
at an 8% balloon payment
in 36 months.
Herjavec:
It's the "Loan Shark Tank."
I'm taking 2.5% equity
as a kicker.
Haley: What I'd like to do is
first explain
the difference in valuation from
the last round to now.
Fair.
You can do that.
But no one's beaten you up
on that yet.
I was gonna
do that work later.
Right. Yeah,
I figured that much,
so I'm just gonna
kind of pre‐empt it.
Thank you. Yeah.
So, since
the last round,
we've de‐risked the company
considerably.
Um, we, uh...
Like I said,
we secured ‐‐
If you don't remember
why it's de‐risked, that's bad.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes
it gets a little ‐‐
That was a bad time
to pause!
[ Laughs ]
We secured the largest
contract manufacturer
in the United States.
We raised enough money
to where we can get to be
cash‐flow positive.
We also are in talks with
the largest big‐box retailer ‐‐
Best Buy.
So, if it's okay with you,
Mr. Wonderful,
I'd like to hear
from the rest of the panel.
Sure.
Herjavec:
I mean, I love ‐‐ I love toys.
I mean, you name it ‐‐
If it goes fast, it's risky,
I'll do it.
For your value...
Mm‐hmm.
... which I'm not even
gonna touch,
I have to buy into
the premise
that this is
a mass‐transportation product,
and regardless
of what Chris Sacca thinks,
the wannabe Millennial...
O'Leary: He's a little old
for that now, isn't he?
Cuban: Yeah, he is.
[ Chuckles ]
Herjavec:
... there's an element of skill
that you have to have
in order to use it
that the average older person
is gonna struggle with.
That would not be me because
I was able to master the device.
Yeah, he was
the king on it.
I don't buy the premise of
a mass‐transportation vehicle.
I'm out.
Sacca: This is a very crowded,
competitive space.
What I'm trying to do
is invest in places
that other people
haven't noticed yet,
and all eyes are on this.
And so, I might be a consumer,
but in the end,
I'm not gonna invest,
so I'm out.
Guys, like Chris said,
there's a lot of people
just focusing
on that market.
I think it's a stretch
partially because we compete,
but for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thanks, Mark.
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you, Mark.
Herjavec:
All right, Lori?
She was just trying to
do Kevin's deal math over here.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: I like it.
I think it's very cool.
I love ingenuity.
But great you have distributors.
People think it's cool,
but people in that business
always think
new things are cool.
They're waiting
for the next new thing.
They buy 50, 100, 300.
They test it.
It doesn't mean
they'll come back for more.
Look, I'm happy with my offer,
but if she goes out,
it won't be 2.5% equity because
it's the nature of a Shark,
when there's no competitors,
to make you
pay a horrible price.
You understand that.
You should tell me
if you're in or out.
Am I competing with you
or not?
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Dave, Chris, and Ryan have
one offer on the table
from Kevin for their electric
skateboard company, Inboard.
But Kevin is threatening
a worse offer if Lori goes out.
Am I competing with you
or not?
I would give you
the $750,000 loan,
8% interest, 36 month,
3% equity.
Is it possible
we can discuss this as a team?
‐Absolutely.
‐Perfect.
‐Awesome.
Herjavec:
Half a point difference
between the two of you.
Half a point.
Otherwise,
exact same offer.
Who do we want more
as a partner?
Do we want Mr. Wonderful,
or do we want Lori?
Lori ‐‐ She's got
the retail side,
and that can be
a huge help.
What should we do?
All right, let's do it.
Let's do it.
All right.
All right?
Yeah, you say it.
Okay, I'm with you.
As many others have learned
in the Shark Tank,
when you leave the tank,
stuff happens.
And stuff did happen
on this deal.
Lori and I decided
to get together on it,
and we're gonna split it,
but there is a cost
because it's
your only offer.
We're gonna give you the
$750,000 for 36 months at 8%,
but we want 5% equity
'cause we want 2.5% each.
You get a whole lot of support
from both of us,
but you're gonna
have to pay a little bit more
because
you left the tank.
Haley:
We want to do a deal
that's gonna actually get by
our investors.
We have a couple
of founders
that have exited
from billion‐dollar companies.
You guys know how big the egos
can be in those circles.
So have we.
We were gonna
counter your offer ‐‐
$750,000, 8% ‐‐
Lori's original deal ‐‐
3%, which we were gonna
turn down,
but now that we have
two Sharks,
we're gonna
be willing to do it.
‐So everybody understands...
‐Yes.
‐Yeah.
...your counter is a
$750,000 loan at 8% interest...
Yeah.
...paid off
after 36 months...
Right.
... and in exchange for that,
you will give them
3% equity
between the two of them.
‐Yeah, 1.5% each.
That's correct.
‐That's correct.
‐1.5%
What do you say,
Kevin, Lori?
Unfortunately, I've discussed
this with my partner, Lori.
We have
no flexibility.
The best deals are ones
where you squirm a little bit.
I want
to see you squirm.
The squirming's gonna be
when I go back to my investors
and put that deal
in front of them.
There's no way I can go above
3% equity with a loan.
How about this ‐‐ We would
be willing to pay more interest.
What about 11%?
Certainly not 11%.
That's more.
[ Laughter ]
But I would ‐‐
I would do the ‐‐
Well, what's ‐‐ What's
your counter ‐‐ That is more.
What's your counter
on the equity if I paid you 9%?
All right, we'll do it
at 9% at 4% equity.
So, $750,000 loan at 9%,
which is nothing.
At least let's just say
we're shareholders,
but, really, it's a tip.
We'll do that deal.
You should take it.
How about this?
I'll do 10% interest.
I need ‐‐ I cannot go above
the 3% equity.
10% interest, 3% equity.
Why can you not
go above the 3%?
'Cause I just know
what our investors have put in
as bounds as what
they're willing to accept,
and the fact
that this is a loan ‐‐
You were offering 4%
when you walked in here.
Chris, when you
walked in here...
Yes.
...you offered 4%
for $750,000 straight equity.
I don't think it's unreasonable
to stay at the 4%,
give you
the $750,000 at 9%.
You walk out of here
with a deal.
You know
you can give us 4%
'cause you asked for that
in the beginning.
You know, I thought Ryan was
the best salesman
I ever met in my life.
I think you're just as good.
You both have a deal.
[ All cheering ]
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Yeah. Lori.
I bet you didn't expect me.
[ Laughs ]
Congrats.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Uh‐huh.
‐Ready?
‐Yeah.
Here we go.
[ All cheering ]
The last two years, we've been
building a rocket ship
at Inboard.
Today we put a button ‐‐
a big red button ‐‐
in front of Lori and Kevin,
and they hit it.
And we can't wait
to ride this thing to the moon.
Yeah, they did.
Hit that button, son!
Narrator: In Season 7,
mother‐and‐daughter team
Gloria Hoffman and Linda Clark
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for their exercise device,
the Simply Fit Board.
I make millionaires this way.
I'm gonna offer you
$125,000 at 20%.
Lori, we would love
to accept your offer.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Hoffman: Before "Shark Tank,"
we had done $575,000 in sales.
24 hours after
being on "Shark Tank,"
we did $1.25 million
in sales.
Clark: The very next day
after "Shark Tank,"
we went on to QVC,
and we sold out of boards
in just six minutes.
Lori had the idea to produce
a Simply Fit Board infomercial.
We expanded across the U. S.,
and now we're in Japan, Europe,
all around the world.
Now just seven months later,
we are up to $9 million,
and it's still climbing.
[ Gasps ]
Oh, my gosh!
Greiner:
Walmart's a big deal because
they have a lot of stores,
and we're in
every single one of them.
When something changes
your life, it's a crying moment.
To see the effect
on Gloria,
to see how much
it's changed her life,
that's why I do what I do.
That's why I'm a Shark.
I'm so thankful.
Nobody deserves it better
than you guys.
You've worked hard.
You created something great.
You're great people.
My belief ‐‐
What goes around comes around.
Thinking about
our journey ‐‐
[ Voice breaking ]
I get emotional every time.
When you're a mom
that wants to show your kids
that anything
is possible ‐‐
I mean, I was
a struggling mom to them,
and overnight,
my whole life changed.
That's perfect.
We are so thankful
for our "Shark Tank" experience,
and I think
that Mom and I are proof
that a grandma
and a stay‐at‐home mom
can become
an overnight success.
It truly is
the American dream.
My name is Renaldo Webb,
and I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
I grew up in New Orleans,
and my sisters and I were raised
by a single mom.
My mom did everything
to support us.
She took a job as a cafeteria
lunch lady to make ends meet.
From an early age, I was always
excited by science and math.
I was the first person
in my family to go to college.
I went to MIT,
where I got my degree in physics
and also found my passion
for entrepreneurship
and organization.
After college, I got
a high‐paying job
helping Fortune 500 companies
with their
manufacturing efforts.
I traveled around the world,
and I really got to see
food production done
at a massive scale.
Here you go.
I realized that
the average consumer has no idea
what's in their food
and would be shocked
if they knew how it was made.
So, how's
the business going?
Webb: It's good.
My mom's gone through so much
in her life.
She made a lot of sacrifices
for me to get to where I am,
and I don't want
to let her down.
I gave up my job
making over $250,000 a year.
I can no longer
help my family
in the ways
that I would like to.
So, if I don't get a deal
from the Sharks,
it's gonna be hard for me
to keep this going.
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Renaldo Webb.
This is Winston.
And we're from Brooklyn,
New York.
I'm the CEO
and founder of PetPlate.
And Winston here ‐‐
He's our chief tasting officer.
And together
we're seeking $100,000
in exchange for a 10% stake
in our company.
PetPlate is the only company
delivering freshly cooked food
tailored for your pet
directly to your door.
Now, Sharks, I'm sure you're
familiar with the health issues
plaguing Americans ‐‐
everything from cancer,
diabetes, high blood pressure,
which is all due in some way
to what we eat.
And unfortunately,
many of these issues are now
finding their way into our pets
from feeding them the scraps
from our overly processed
food supply chain.
Over 60% of dogs and cats
in America are overweight.
Many more are suffering
from serious issues
such as diabetes and allergies.
And one in two dogs in America
will die from cancer.
So, PetPlate
is solving this issue
by educating
and empowering pet parents
to have healthier
and happier pets.
So, who wants to see what
actually goes into PetPlate?
We do.
Bring it on.
So, we only use all‐natural
ingredients in PetPlate
no different than what you'd buy
at a grocery store
to feed your own family.
And today we've
brought over the ingredients
for our lamb
and vegetables dish.
It contains very lean lamb.
Put that in there.
Then we also have eggs.
This is all
of our protein source.
We use potatoes
and sweet potatoes.
Then we also add in...
[ Laughter ]
Winston can
smell it coming.
He's so hungry.
Then we add in some peas
and carrots.
We have pumpkin.
This is for fiber.
It makes
the morning walks great.
And then finally, we have
our healthy oils and vitamins.
So, Sharks, who wants to give
Winston's favorite dish a try?
I'm in.
[ Laughter ]
Mark.
I'm in.
Yeah, Mark
will eat anything.
As I said, this is our
lamb and vegetables dish here.
How about you, Lori?
Do you want to give it
a little try, as well?
Yeah, sure,
I'll share with Chris.
Awesome. Thank you.
You can go first?
[ Laughs ]
Here you go.
Thank you.
Yeah, of course.
Hi!
Oh, man,
that's a lucky dog.
Herjavec:
Mark will try it.
Yeah, give it to Mark.
He'll eat anything.
Perfect.
I don't know.
Herjavec:
And what's it like?
It's good.
Buddy, can you sit?
Down.
Good boy!
Herjavec: Aww.
Okay, go!
Cuban: Yeah.
Get it, Winston.
So, this is
a home delivery service...
Yes.
... for fresh,
real food...
Exactly.
... for pets.
Exactly. So, you can imagine it
as a plated, for example...
Yeah.
... but it's freshly cooked,
so ready to go
from box to bowl as soon as you
get your delivery.
Is it a subscription service?
Do you sign up?
So, right now you sign up
for a month, 3, 6, or 12.
Our average subscription length
is three months right now.
O'Leary:
What's the price?
How much does it cost?
What's the pricing?
So, we charge this
by the pound.
So, it varies
by the price of your dog.
If you have a small,
little Chihuahua,
it's gonna be around 30 ‐‐
30 bucks a month.
And how many meals
do I get per month?
Greiner:
There goes the table.
[ Laughter ]
So you get your full ‐‐
So you sign up
on our website.
You go in, and you put in
the weight of your dog.
And then it takes you
to our meal‐plan options.
You can try between getting
the full PetPlate
meal plan subscription ‐‐
so 14 meals a week.
And then we space it out
in terms of two deliveries
a week for you.
And how much is it
per week?
Webb: Depends on
the size of the dog.
Depends on
How many times
do you got to say it?
All right, so,
I got a Chihuahua.
So, how many subscribers
do you have?
So we have just over 100
subscribers right now ‐‐ 105.
100? That's it?
How long have you been
in business?
For about
eight months now.
We're actually just hitting
the eight‐month mark.
And it's just in New York?
You're just doing locally?
So, right now, we can ship
to anywhere
within a 300‐mile radius
of New York City,
but I am laser‐focused
on making this
an urban type of service.
Why don't you have
more than 100 subscribers?
Right now,
I am a one‐man show.
In order to emulate
the models that are out there
with the big guys,
they've gone through
this multi‐year
logistics problem
of building centers
in all the major areas
so they can fulfill.
So, how
we're different is
it's far simpler to cook
for a dog.
We have a set menu ‐‐
about six options.
We can cook
about 200 to 300 pounds of food
in about three to four hours.
What's your background?
I was born in New Orleans.
My mom was a cafeteria worker
at the local public high school.
I was passionate about
science and mathematics.
Cool.
I then went to MIT,
where I graduated
with a degree
in physics there.
Wow.
I realized
I wasn't the savant
that was gonna
discover gravitational waves,
even though
I really wanted to.
But I found my passion
for organization
and entrepreneurship.
I traveled all around the world
helping Fortune 500 companies
with their supply‐chain ‐‐
manufacturing, like,
on the factory floor.
And that's where I got the bulk
of my pet‐food experience ‐‐
watching this food get made,
seeing the ingredients go in,
and seeing why the health
of American pets is ‐‐
Honestly, it's dismal.
You know, I really wanted
to change that.
Wow, Renaldo,
you're one impressive guy.
Greiner:
Yeah, very impressive.
Thank you. Thank you.
But I'm curious.
So, you quit your job then.
Yes.
And you're running this
full time by yourself?
Exactly. But
the delivery couriers we use ‐‐
They're being paid in full.
We're still losing
a little bit of money
on the per‐delivery cost
and the logistics.
How much did you raise,
Renaldo?
I didn't raise any money.
Good for you.
You used
all your own money?
I put in about $80,000
of my own money.
Good for you.
Wow.
O'Leary:
My big issue with this deal
is knowing that the challenges
we had with Plated to get scale,
you're gonna need
a ton of money.
No, no, we're not.
Why not?
We're already
delivering and doing
over 150 deliveries
with one courier.
Where's the tipping point?
How do you get to...big?
So, when we hit 500 dogs,
this is a half‐a‐million‐dollar
business.
Why don't I,
in a commercial kitchen,
create the best pet food,
premium product,
but not make it
completely fresh?
Why deliver it
to people?
If it kind of came down to it,
and I realized, "You know what?
I need to put natural
preservatives in this to win,"
that's what I would do.
See, Renaldo, for me, like,
I see you as a real hero.
My concern is I see this
as a challenging business
because of obstacles
that have to do more with
how many people
will care enough to invest
in the fresh,
home‐cooked meals.
Robert's point of pivoting,
possibly,
and creating something
that's easier to sustain
seems to make sense to me,
but it doesn't fit your mission.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate all the feedback
on that, Lori.
I'm not sure
that the market is there.
If there was a cause
in a small community
that's deeply passionate
about their dogs,
it would have spread
to more than 100 users
after eight months.
I'm sorry.
I admire
what you're doing,
but I don't see the business
right now.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
And, Chris, I notice
you haven't asked a question.
I would love to be able
to convince you
why I believe
there's a market for this.
I'm deeply conflicted
on this deal, man.
I hear about your background,
and I think
to have attained that
is incredibly impressive.
To go as a black kid
from New Orleans to MIT
and to have all that educational
achievement is incredible.
You're like the dream partner
I would love to work with
or back
in any of our companies.
Problem is
you chose the one
that we're competing with you
in from UberRUSH, right?
We're pushing couriers
all over the world right now,
and we're moving food
all over the world right now.
So, for me,
it's harder to get super‐excited
about funding a guy
who's gonna knock right head‐on
into one of
our businesses.
If this thing doesn't pan out,
please get in touch immediately,
'cause I know we'd be
a great force,
but I can't do this deal.
I'm out.
Thank you, Chris.
I appreciate that.
Renaldo, I think
you're amazing, right?
Your accomplishments
speak for themselves.
The thing about
the pet business,
whether it's
food or otherwise,
is that it's
an all‐in business.
You've got to eat, sleep,
and drink pets 24‐7.
But I'm not
a 24‐by‐7 pet guy.
And you need that infrastructure
and support around you
from people who have
that same mind‐set.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I'm living this right now
with Plated,
and they're doing
quite well,
but they've learned the hard way
how difficult it is to scale.
Our biggest issue remains
to be competition for customers,
and we are delivering, and we're
having sustained customers.
I'm sorry.
I'm not gonna
take the journey with you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Congratulations, man.
You're gonna crush it.
Good luck.
Thank you for the time.
I'm feeling
a lot of frustration
just because I'm tired
of hearing "no."
[ Voice breaking ]
But it doesn't matter
how hard I have to work.
So... yeah.
Very frustrated, but, you know,
it was never gonna be easy,
and I know that.
And it never has been, so...
We know our business more
than anyone else in the world.
Let's power pose.
This is my house.
This is our house!
Man:
Tape's rolling. Stand by.
Let's go! Go! Go!
Narrator: Next up
is a new generation of products
designed to optimize physical
and mental function.
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Geoffrey Woo.
My name is
Michael Brandt.
We're from San Francisco,
California.
Our company is Nootrobox,
and we're seeking $2 million
in exchange for a 5% stake
in our company.
Oh! Hello!
[ Laughter ]
So Nootrobox isn't
any ordinary company.
We're a team of bio‐hackers,
researchers, and technologists.
And we develop, manufacture,
and sell nootropics.
Nootropics are
a rapidly growing market
of brain‐enhancing consumables
and supplements.
We're from Silicon Valley,
where some of the most creative
and ambitious people
in the entire world are.
And these people are
constantly trying to eke
more productivity
out of each and every day.
Bio‐hacking is all about
the experimentation
and controlling of inputs
into the human body
as if our bodies are
a complex
but still understandable
computer system.
We've looked
at something
that hundreds of millions
of Americans put into their body
on a daily basis ‐‐
a classic cup of coffee.
We've looked at ways
to re‐engineer coffee
for something
that's significantly better
for performance.
And it's called Go Cubes
Chewable Coffee!
It's convenient
and portable,
you can put it
right in your pocket,
and unlike any ordinary
cup of joe,
it's precisely dosed with
caffeine and other nootropics
so you get
the kick of coffee,
but it's much more balanced
and steady.
The future of coffee is here,
and we want you Sharks
to take a bite out of it.
Herjavec:
Can we try it?
Yeah.
So, Geoff, just want to be
clear, it was $2 million for 5%?
Correct.
And to be clear, you named it
after me ‐‐ Cubes, right?
[ Chuckles ]
Of course.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Sure.
Do you mind
if you tell us
more about what's in them
before we eat them?
It's ‐‐
I don't want
to get roofied.
[ Laughs ]
So, you have three different
flavors of Go Cubes.
from lightest to darkest,
you have latte,
drip coffee, and mocha.
Each cube has
50 milligrams of caffeine.
It's a half a cup
of coffee.
How much sugar?
Six grams of sugar
per cube.
Oh, wow.
It's really good.
And one thing that's really
great about Go Cubes is because
it's exactly that
50 milligrams of caffeine,
you know exactly
what you're getting.
But this is not
the first supplement‐type item
that has a defined amount
of caffeine in it.
So, our background is
bio‐hackers, right?
But first ‐‐
first, lots of people
call themselves
bio‐hackers.
Two years ago,
it was just someone
who was trying to come up
with a better formulation.
Yeah, but I think ‐‐
So, let's just talk in terms
of what you're actually doing.
Yeah, so, I think in terms
of actually speaking
about the community ‐‐
A community of what?
Of people that are
bio‐hacking with us.
So, for instance,
we fast.
We do intermittent fasting
on a weekly basis,
where for 36 hours straight,
we consume zero calories.
Just water.
Why is that good?
So, actually,
caloric restriction is actually
one of the most compelling ways
to increase longevity.
So, you're looking at nutrition.
You're looking at activity.
You're looking at sleep.
You're looking
at all these different things
and how
they impact the body.
Yeah.
So, there is a space here,
but why ‐‐
Okay,
but why is this ‐‐
Why is this cube
worth $40 million?
We started the business in 2014.
We did $55,000 in sales.
And we've done, year‐to‐date,
almost $1 million revenue.
And we're getting 17%
month‐over‐month revenue growth.
Are you guys scientists?
Are you guys engineers?
We're
computer scientists.
Both of you are
computer scientists?
We have four MB/PhDs
on our team.
Okay.
Greiner:
Let's go back to the basics.
What is this product?
Yeah, yeah.
Basically,
from a performance ‐‐
Why is this special?
So, there's amino acid found
in green tea called L‐theanine.
So, caffeine
and L‐theanine together ‐‐
So, there's actually a bunch of
trials showing the effects
of that active
combination ingredient
versus caffeine alone
versus placebo.
So, simple reaction time
reduces 50% more in terms of ‐‐
so a baseline
of 330 milliseconds ‐‐
Okay, so this is ‐‐
Okay ‐‐
So, what ‐‐
what ‐‐ what ‐‐
A better absorption?
Better methods?
A simple reaction time,
increased semantic memories.
Hey, Robert.
You just ate one of these.
Can you remember where we are
in this pitch?
[ Laughs ]
Sorry.
What did you say?
Hey, you've got an opportunity
to tell this story
to 8 million to 10 million
Americans right now
on a recurring basis.
The most valuable prime time
airtime in the world right now.
And you're blowing it.
Tell this story.
Well said, Chris.
Look, there's things
out there
that are better
for your cognition
than just your ordinary
cup of coffee.
We're at the forefront
of doing research
and actually figuring out
what these things are
and telling
the story about it.
O'Leary:
Guys, I've made a lot of money
as an investor
obeying the laws of gravity.
And I think you guys are flying
very close to the sun.
Your valuation is the highest
I've ever seen on the carpet.
I'm not saying
you can't pull it off,
but it won't be
with my money.
I'm out.
Thanks.
Geoff, this is
the highest valuation
we've ever had
on "Shark Tank."
For sugar cubes.
We've never had any company
for $40 million.
At what point does the company
become worth that?
Look, when you go
to invest in Apple,
you're not
investing in Apple
because of their current
product lineup.
[ Laughs ]
Let him go.
Let him go. Let him go.
Brandt:
You're investing in Apple
because of their approach
to technology...
[ Laughs ]
...their ability to do R&D,
to product‐ize,
and to bring it
to market.
[ All talking indistinctly ]
But that's
what we're asking you.
Herjavec: You're not giving us
that answer, Michael.
You came in,
and you gave us sugar cubes.
We've asked you that
like 20 times.
2 billion cups of coffee are
drank every day.
People like coffee.
That's everyone's
go‐to nootropic.
That's a different market,
though, Michael.
It's a different market.
It's not really different
'cause that's what people have
for performance.
Why are people mixing powders
off the Internet?
Michael, I accept the fact
that you guys are really smart.
But there's a responsibility
that you have
when you're presenting
at a $40 million value.
If you can't
justify that today,
I'm not really listening
to you anymore
'cause I can't get over
that single thought.
I don't care
how smart you are.
what your background is.
I don't think you did a good job
of explaining that to me.
I'm out.
All right, thanks.
I mean, look, I'm not offended
at all by your price.
And I can see how you can get
to your type of price
based on your sales
and trajectory.
That said,
it scares the hell out of me.
I've tried nootropics.
That's what people use
to go on 48‐hour coding binges.
But at the end of the day,
you're left with a headache,
lack of recall sometimes.
I'm worried about the long‐term
consequences, and so I'm out.
All of our ingredients
are generally regarded as safe.
"Generally regarded"
is not the same as "safe."
I think that you're much more
into the scientist brain
and not realizing
that some of us up here
weren't understanding
what it was
you were trying
to sell to us.
I feel it would be helpful
to you if you got somebody
who was more sales‐oriented
that would be able
to communicate for you,
when you need it,
about what your vision is
in going down the sales path.
I am out.
I'm not investing today.
But I wish you good luck.
Appreciate it.
Part of the problem
in Silicon Valley is
that the valuations
are priced to perfection
because
that's their approach.
And if you were to come in here
priced with uncertainty,
okay, then we might have been
able to make the deal,
but you priced it in the Silicon
Valley way, and so I'm out.
Cool.
All right.
Thanks so much.
Thanks, you guys.
Good luck, you guys.
Cool.
Thank you.
Good luck, guys.
Woo:
Bio‐hacking is meant to spawn
multi‐billion‐dollar companies,
right?
So, $40 million
valuation ‐‐
You know, it's gonna be cheap
in the long run.
It just scares the hell
out of me as an investor,
and it scares the hell out of me
as a human being
'cause I don't think
we know
the long‐term consequences
of this stuff.
I'll tell you what scares
the hell out of me ‐‐
$40 million for sugar.
Narrator: Next into the tank
are entrepreneurs with a product
that makes gourmet cooking
a breeze.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Lisa,
and this is my husband, Abe.
We're the founders
of Nomiku,
and we hail
from San Francisco.
We're seeking $250,000 in
exchange for 5% of our business.
The top chefs of the world
have a secret tool.
Sous Vide is
a method of cooking
where you take
vacuum‐sealed food
and put it in a precise,
low‐temperature water bath.
It's a top chef's
secret weapon
because it allows you to craft
delicious, perfect dishes
conveniently
and consistently.
When I worked at top‐tier
three Michelin Star restaurants,
I lusted after
these machines,
but they were
thousands of dollars.
Luckily,
I met him at the gym.
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
That's where you pick up
plasma physicists.
[ Laughter ]
And he made an at‐home version
just for me.
It changed our lives.
And now we're changing the lives
of home cooks everywhere
with the first ever home
Sous Vide immersion circulator.
Take any pot
and fill it with water,
then you clip Nomiku
to the side of the pot.
You put your ingredients
and seasonings
into a zip‐seal
plastic bag.
Put the bag in the water
and walk away.
Our app controls the time
and the temperature
so that you come back
to a perfectly cooked meal.
With a little bit
of TV magic...
[ Laughter ]
... we have some steaks
that have been cooked already
with a Nomiku.
Because we're cooking
at a low temperature,
it doesn't have
that delicious crust around it.
We're gonna
finish that right now.
How long does ‐‐
does it take to cook?
Two hours.
But you don't have to
babysit it.
You can just put the bag in
and walk away.
So, Lisa, we're Sharks.
Are we gonna get to try some?
Absolutely.
So, we start with a perfectly
cooked shrimp cocktail.
And then we have
that perfectly cooked steak.
And we have
a chocolate‐coconut custard.
Lisa, what did you used to do?
'Cause you're a natural at this.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
I worked in
the restaurant industry.
And I'm the face of the company,
so I give a lot of talks.
Cuban: Appreciate it.
Thank you.
And now, folks, this is a meal
that we made for you
with vodka that's
been Nomikued
with rhubarb, strawberry,
and limes.
Herjavec: Thank you!
Cheers.
Thank you so much, Scott.
This steak is
fantastic.
[ Chuckles ]
At some point,
you were discussing the value
of this business ‐‐
$5 million, right?
Yes.
You must have sales.
We do, Kevin.
All right.
So, we've sold them
since 2012.
We have...
We have $3 million
in sales.
Wow.
So, how and where
have you been selling it?
We sold them direct
from our website
and from
online retailers.
And we just got a P. O.
from Williams‐Sonoma.
Herjavec: I'm not a big chef.
Why would I do this
instead of making it on a stove
or on a barbecue?
What's the benefit
of this whole process?
It's one‐button cooking.
It's like a ‐‐ It's like
a slow cooker, a crock pot.
It's a
set‐it‐and‐forget‐it.
I cook, as well.
I like to do Burgundian dishes.
What is that?
What's
a Burgundian dish?
Burgundian, for example ‐‐
calves liver.
You don't want
to overcook it.
So, Lisa, I don't know
any of that stuff.
Do you do that
with all organs of your kills?
Could you tell us
what it costs?
Yes, it costs $199.
How much
have you raised?
So we ‐‐ In 2012,
we had a seed round of 875k.
And then last year,
we did a note of $2 million.
Ooh.
$2 million?
Yes.
Cuban: Last year?
So what was the valuation
of the seed round?
The seed round
is $6 million.
And then was there a warrant
on the note?
The note is a 10 cap.
The note's a convert?
Correct.
It's straight convert.
Right.
Hmm.
Cuban: Guys, I think
it's a great product,
but I just don't see
the momentum
that I think
you should have.
I don't really understand
the competitive threats
since I don't know
the industry.
So, I'm out.
So grateful for your time, Mark.
Thank you.
I have had Sous Vide before.
I think it's interesting,
but I do think
that a lot of people just like
to throw steak on the grill,
and they don't want to do
a secondary step
to char their meat
or get it crispy.
I'm not going to invest.
I wish you the best.
I'm out.
Thank you
very much, Lori.
Let me just clear the deck.
Sous Vide ‐‐ Moo Vide ‐‐ I ‐‐
Pbht.
It's all French to me.
It is French.
[ Chuckles ]
Aha.
The idea of planning my meal
like that is just ‐‐
is just foreign.
And I like to invest in stuff
that I have a taste for.
It's just not a market for me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Abe: Thank you.
I mean, it's funny. It doesn't
matter what it's called.
It just
tastes delicious.
And I just want
to know ‐‐
How did you get to the valuation
you're asking for here?
We expect to have
$5 million in revenue
in the next 12 months,
and our valuation is consistent
with other companies with that
sort of revenue projection.
Basically, you're not gonna
make much money,
even after $5 million.
But are you coming in
under the cap of the last round?
That's...
We know that if we bring
a Shark on,
you guys are gonna be
very hard‐core.
You see the value
of having a Shark on the team.
That's right.
We do.
Well, you have two Sharks
left ‐‐ Kevin and Chris.
Let's see, Lisa,
if you can get a deal
from one or both of them.
I would love both because
one Shark is like a volcano.
Two Sharks is like a lightning
striking that volcano.
Sharknado.
[ Laughter ]
Sharknado!
I have two constituencies that
I think this would appeal to.
One are the customers of Plated,
of which I'm an inventor.
They'll be supportive
of a Shark deal, obviously.
And the other are
my quarter of a million people
who have bought my wines.
They're all foodies.
I make the suggestions.
They believe me
because I'm really good at it,
and I have the palate.
I'll do this deal ‐‐
$250,000.
I want 10%.
We really respect
that offer.
Thank you.
It comes from the heart.
Well, we'd love to hear
what Chris has to say.
I would, too.
Chris?
That's 10%
of your company.
Correct.
Are you gonna take
a board seat over there?
I don't need a board seat.
I need 10%.
Are you gonna co‐office
with them?
My bottom line is
this is a lot of risk,
and you know it, too.
I'm very curious, though,
about this equity.
Let's talk about
how those notes work.
So you had
$2 million worth of investment
come in
on a document that says,
"We're investing as if
the price were $10 million."
But later on,
the price is $5 million,
and they convert
into the company.
Subject to that $10 million cap,
it comes all the way down
at a big discount now.
Those investors are gonna own
most of your company.
You guys, as the founders,
aren't gonna own anything.
Just to be clear,
if you do a deal at $5 million,
how much of the company
do you end up owning?
How much do the investors
end up owning?
Right now we own 51%.
Well, you're not after this.
The biggest allure to this deal
is you, Lisa.
I think you're the package
right here.
Thank you.
I love your presence.
I love how well you've handled
these questions.
You're an amazing
entrepreneurial force.
As we talk about the terms
of this deal, though,
I really get worried
when I see a deal
that leaves you not owning much
of the company at all.
How do you help me
get past that?
Sure. We're here
with that deal
to make it
appetizing for you.
That's why I'm up here.
I'm ‐‐
So, are you throwing my deal
under the bus?
I get that, but I don't want
to work with people
who don't have a ton of upside
left in their own company.
They're not happy.
We'd love to give you
adviser shares.
Lisa, I'm gonna make it
easier for you.
I'm gonna make it
Chris Sacca,
give us a deal.
I'm out.
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Chris Sacca is interested
in Abe and Lisa's
Sous Vide machine, Nomiku,
but is concerned
that his investment would result
in them diluting
their equity so much,
they would no longer have skin
in the game.
The best deals are the deals
where we are all super‐excited
to get out of bed every morning
because we're all gonna make
a lot of money.
We're all gonna have
positive impact.
So, if we go and do this deal,
you guys would be diluted
to the teens.
And so at the end of this round,
how much of the company
would you guys like to own?
See, I think a couple
owning 10% of the company
doesn't get it done.
Okay, what do you...?
What do you think?
It's the craziest deal
I've ever seen.
I ‐‐
Greiner: It is.
I don't want you guys
to shoot yourselves in the foot.
We won't.
If this is your life's work,
and this is your passion,
you should be fighting as hard
as you can to not give it away.
We're listening to you.
Because this takes off
with us together.
Here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you 250k...
for 10% of the company...
contingent upon you going back
to your other investors
and making sure you get
enough stock back from them
that you own 40% of the company
at the end of the deal.
I get 10%, you get 40%,
they get 50%.
Would you ‐‐ Would you be open
to a counter of 8%?
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh!
Really?!
After all that ‐‐
all that work he did for you
and looked out for you,
you're gonna
rake him over for 2%?
So, you guys are
suddenly ‐‐
I'm doing
what he told me to do.
I don't think you're pausing
to think about it.
I think you're just
reflexively trying to squeeze
a couple more points
out of me.
So, pausing
to think about it ‐‐
Don't negotiate
for the sake of negotiating.
Lisa: Okay. Okay.
That deal's not possible
without taking down
your other investors about 15%.
They know that.
But they get to negotiate
with them.
Those investors are
all grown‐ups
who got into a risky company
earlier on.
Do we have a deal?
We're gonna take it.
All right!
Let's do it!
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Cheers.
Right on, man.
Thank you.
Hey, congrats.
This is cool.
Yeah,
thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
All right, guys.
Greiner: Bye.
Oh, they're skipping!
Herjavec:
Oh, they're skipping down ‐‐
Lisa: Wow, Chris Sacca is
the freaking bomb.
We're gonna get
such a fighter on our side.
He really ‐‐ He really loves us
and looked out for us.
That was amazing.
They obviously
undervalued themselves
around the first
and second round.
No, I ‐‐ Look, Chris,
I think it's a great deal
for you. I really, really do.
The earlier investors
took a risk.
They knew they were
taking a risk.
Things didn't play out for them
exactly like they wanted.
It's not
the first down ‐‐
So, I don't feel bad
taking it out of their hides.
It's not
the first‐down round.
the last‐down round...
That's true.
... that'll ever happen.